-Today is Friday
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was running a bit behind.
You guys are the best.
I'd like to write out
some thank-you notes right now.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
-[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Fantastic.
-Happy Friday.
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Father's Day,
for being the one day each year
you get to say "I love you"
to your dad's nostrils
over FaceTime.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
new Jack & Coke in a can,
for telling your guests,
"This barbecue is not going
to end well."
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
You drank all of them?
-Yeah.
[Indistinct] over here.
-You drank all? Oh, man.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, New York Times
crossword puzzles,
for making me feel
like a genius on Monday
and a total moron by Sunday.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I don't know.
I don't know words."
-Yeah. "What?"
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
roadside fireworks tents,
because nothing is
more reassuring
than an explosives store
designed
to pack up and leave town
as fast as possible.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
"Let's go!
-"Get in the car!"
[ Whistling ]
[ Southern accent ]
It done blowed up."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
clicking Skip Credits,
for being what I do because I
don't have 45 seconds to spare
while I watch three hour-long
episodes of TV.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I don't have time for that."
-"A waste of my time."
-Yeah, waste of my time.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, centipedes,
for being the Rockettes of bugs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, drawing the sun
in the corner...
[ Laughter ]
-What?
What?!
[ Laughter ]
-...helping me hide my deepest,
darkest secret --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what the other
three-quarters of the sun
look like.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Unless you do a drawing.
-That was my actual drawing
-That was your drawing
you drew today?
-from this morning, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And you sent a thank-you note
to your own drawing?
[ Laughter ]
-Was it to my own drawing?
♪♪
[ Fresh laughter ]
Thank you, ripped jeans,
for letting my knees
get the window seat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, that's what I'm
talking about.
Those are our "Thank You Notes."
We'll be right back
[ Cheering ]
with Tracee Ellis Ross.